docteur boileau bonjour bonjour docteur
boileau ceux qui espéraient qu'on est un
chiffre aujourd'hui un plafond aux
démissions ils vont être déçus ce qu'on
sait c'est que selon vous le niveau
actuel n'est pas acceptable mais comment
docteur boileau on va arriver à un
nouveau plafond sachant que le premier
ministre dit c'est vous l'expert et vous
devez mais c'est pas à vous de convenir
qui est acceptable ou non donc comment
on va arriver à un chiffre
écoutez la première des choses c'est que
nous réalisons et je pense que nous
serons pas les seuls ni les premiers 1
de souligner que les émissions à cet
auteur ne peuvent poser des risques pour
l'assaut dans les eaux caractérisée en
partie pour le cancer du poumon on voit
que ça a un impact pas un impact qui en
terme de nombre qui est exorbitant mais
si un impact réel et c'est un impact qui
lorsqu'on le regarde par rapport à ce
qui est normalement accepté nous le
dépensons beaucoup du côté de la
communauté de rouyn noranda mais
particulièrement dans le périmètre mais
sinon maintenant
qu'il quartier notre dame il ya d'autres
effets possibles de cette fonderie niort
et il faut obtenir compte donc nous nous
empressons pour des prochaines journées
quelques prochaines semaines à 40 et les
risques que ça veut dire quand on est
exposé à cettolo à saint
ouen 15 watts est ce que nous allons
faire puisque effectivement le
gouvernement est intéressé tout comme si
je comprends bien l'entreprise a trouvé
un espace de convenance pour que ces
risques le soin minimiser alors nous
allons travailler avec des propositions
qui nous seront faites de dire ben voila
si nous cheminons pour eux une
diminution un tel niveau est ce que ça
aura un impact sur la santé de quelle
nature soit il pour que les gens soient
éclairés le plus possible de dire voilà
ce que ça voudrait dire donc on aurait
combine maladie donc honoraires est ce
qu'on aurait des risques de cancers ou
des risques de bébés de petit point avec
son oubli risque même de difficultés
d'apprentissage scolaire pour d emphase
que ce que c'est c'est réaliste de
croire que ça peut vraiment minimiser
lisez moi je crois qu'on est sur un
chemin qui est ouvert devant le film
peut nous permettre dans un horizon
respectable de dire dans les prochaines
semaines dit à peine quelques prochains
mois d'arriver à une conclusion qui sera
raisonnable et les yeux et la tension et
je vous dirais les heures l'impression
que les gens auront autour de cette
fonderie you dans la communauté demain
au rang de raconter beaucoup à ce que ce
sera pour eux accepté quelque chose qui
comptera beaucoup et qui est en route
pour être justement
quatre pays comme il faut du coup au
delà de l'établissement de la ctaq
l'acceptabilité sociale après des
négociations entre la fonderie et le
gouvernement mais je comprends que vous
n'excluez pas que ça dépasse le 3
nanogrammes par mètre cube qui est en ce
moment la norme provinciale
bien sûr que ça peut être très difficile
pour une entreprise avec une telle
production industrielle de ramener le
tout ce qu'on retrouve dans l'air
ambiant dans un contexte sous l'eau
potable ça ça peut être pratiquement
impossible alors est-ce que trois c'est
un niveau qui est le seul niveau
acceptable peut-être que pour certains
citoyens c'est quoi mais lorsqu'on
externe l impact est d'avoir des taux
est supérieur qui pourrait aussi de
façon plus grands le prêt de quelques
fois plus est-ce que c'est toujours
acceptable ce sera la question leur
demander puisque vous savez les rappels
internationaux de ce côté de son ventre
rond varier un peu de yoga des repas qui
sont plus sévères d'autres moins et il y
en a qui sont plus modernes
malheureusement n'y pas eu d'étude très
très récentes ont sa part on s'était
attendu au fil des années parce que la
grande île qui américaine plus en une
nouvelle posture de ce côté là et ce
n'est pas le cas ça arrivera sûrement
après se règlent cette règle
d'assainissement pour une progressive
d'enfance datant mais moi je crois qu'on
peut qu'on peut naviguer avec un
certaine sorte une exposition encore
possible que ce soit et maîtrise hier
yali il y avait le premier ministre
françois legault qui excluait pas la
fermeture pure et simple de lui qui
avait pas de clans pour réduire les
amène les émanations d'arsenic quel
niveau d'émanations à votre avis
nécessiterait de fermer l'usiné
sans la cam par mètre cube ce qui est
actuellement permise si on maintient
cette permission donc tout de ça très
correct à votre avis permettrait de
faire fonctionner musique mais attention
actuellement même si six ans l'anneau g
de les mesures prises dans les années
hippies récente samantha 87 en moyenne
durant l'année passée donc en gros de ce
qui est actuellement pourrait être
acceptable mais faut pas que ça soit 86
de faut que ça soit nettement plus bas
et il faut voir la progression ce parce
que vous savez l'entreprise et c'est pas
en ajustant sur un petit module le à
l'intérieur mon favori so fabrice ça va
demander des changements dans leur
processus industriels et des changements
compter des innovations probablement
intégrer notre sur nos coeurs il ya un
effort à faire ça peut prendre du temps
de se leurrer ce que ça veut prendre
trop de temps ces stocks qui restent à
vie donc on ne peut pas tous les mêmes
paramètres transformer mais je reste
convaincu que les responsables de
l'industrie travaille francs en pot
essayez de convenir de nouvelles façons
de faire qui elles seront proposées et
que nous pourrons analyser à la lumière
de nos expertises et donner un avis sur
aussi si c'est ça ça va donner ça et de
bénéfice les gens trouve de tout et
c'est à ce soit la population
l'industrie ou bien sûr du gouvernement
docteur boileau un mot sur la colline je
sais que vous allez faire le point
demain avec le ministre la fente et
christian dubé mais est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à de nous un retour de
mesures sanitaires vu le convoi par
exemple une courbe ascendante
supporter des hospitalisations des
personnes en soins intensifs
c'est une question extrêmement
importante et qui est très pertinent
parce qu'effectivement on voit une
croissance sexuellement mais cette
croissance up ne nous amène pas dans des
dents des paramètres qui sont
profondément déstabilisant pour le
système de soins même si nous
reconnaissons que actuellement en pleine
période estivale il peut manquer de
personnel pour des vacances bien méritée
mais nous ne sommes pas en route pour
imposer de nouvelles mesures
populationnelle il n'y aurait pas des
motifs pour face en ce moment donc on
attendra quand même le point sur la
situation plus complet demain docteur le
bois l'eau vous êtes vous êtes directeur
national de santé publique vous remercie
beaucoup bonne soirée
merci madame des mauvais soirs